this workshop is a part of a new
experiment or an idea or intervention
that we have been thinking about for the
last four or five months of how we can
enable authentic meaningful relevant
learning experiences for high school
students with math science and English
education including life skills and
professional skills and values mediated
by technology including technology and
meaningful ways and at scale when we
began discussing this project it really
began because of an very early
interaction between the data trusts mr.
Tata himself and the MIT on whether
these new technological possibilities
that were altering the character of
learning experiences world over for
students could somehow be made to play a
much more central role in how indian
school offered experiences to high
school students we really want to look
at it in a very integrity way where
technology is used is an integral part
of how curriculum is not only jelly
world but developed so that it's it's
appropriate to the kinds of learning
outcomes and learning experiences that
we desire to have some of which might be
realized in other ways but some of which
we think can be more effectively and
efficiently done with heart full of
prudent views into integrated use of
technology the top thing that we really
try to do is create highly engaged and
motivated students so we really think
that in order for students to learn
particular content in math or science or
language learning that we need to engage
them first we have a lot to learn even
from past kinds of experiments have been
done in research that's been done online
in terms of the way that people learn
and collaborate online I think really
that today's MOOCs and today's online
learning should be better informed by
things like computer-supported
collaborative learning we are trying to
build community in our MOOC courses it's
something that's really been absent a
lot of online learning environments that
are typically content delivery to an
individual but not about creating
community and creating communities of
learners
it kind of can have two sorts of changes
to the world one is it can make sort of
quantitative changes in the way that we
have education so it can make things
more efficient it can make things scale
it can reduce costs but the other side
we have qualitative changes things like
educational technology can change our
pedagogy in the way we teach it can
change the kinds of activities that we
deliver to students it can change the
ways in which we engage the students
what will happen in this workshop is
exactly the kind of collaborative and
engaged process that we hope we can
model for when this thing's actually
rolling out so this is a planning
exercise and at the same time it's a
it's a real doing exercise if you look
at a lot of the online work that we have
there are many design flaws lot of it is
very static text which has just been
digitized so we need to clearly look at
our design as well to see why this is
not enabling teachers to transition or
change their pedagogical ideas currently
we are preparing an online teacher
education course for elementary science
teachers I teach in the Department of
elementary education at lady shri ram
college which is a teacher education
program i have been working a lot with
the school teachers to enrich the
classroom teaching using various
technology tools we are running a
virtual open school project in rajasthan
the focus of the project is to work with
students and children who are you know
in the age group 14 to 18 will dropped
out of school but want to appear for the
open school exams and get back into the
schooling system you're going to
experience this design lab process that
we have done all over the world with all
different types of educators
administrators students to come up with
new ideas will do brainstorming once you
have one idea for a learning experience
will transition to building the
prototypes will present and get feedback
from each other test your design refine
your designs
then actually transition to documenting
them as a learning experience one of the
really interesting things I heard from
you all yesterday was this focus on the
student and and engaging them and
motivating them and that's really the
heart of using design thinking it's all
about improving the user experience and
in most of your cases that will be the
student we think taking and meaningfully
initiative involving technology and
education will require us to build a
community such as this which can
actually translate valuable curricular
ideas into practices that can be
implemented in school with a selection
of technology not merely because it
exists is but because it can actually
contribute to furthering the ideas that
we believe are important and at the same
time thinking on how can this effort of
active learning we made much more
massively available in India where do we
go after this well one immediate thing
that we want to do is to pick up some of
the ideas which have been generated in
this workshop to go into a few schools
to actually try them out and see what it
takes to do and give more concrete shape
to this initiative itself